lifelong local journalist jose tejada is
a reluctant politician his candidacy for
a seat in congress is being promoted by
the young protesters who rocked the city
last spring and who are now looking for
a change of leadership
my obsession is to empower the youth
they have opened our eyes and said they
don't want the country they have
received
tejada has become famous in colombia for
his relentless coverage of the brutal
police response to the protest
hundreds of thousands marched across the
country against economic inequality
corruption and the government's plans to
raise taxes on the middle class
but nowhere was the response more
violent than in cali where armed
civilians openly shot at protesters
along with the police
i saw kids losing their eyes fall dead
at our side and i said enough
their voices deserve to
one of many first-time candidates
endorsed by leftist parties hoping to
change the balance of power in congress
long controlled by conservatives
fearing their growth some politicians on
the right are condemning last year's
protests calling them agueria take over
others while more moderate still believe
the protesters went too far the citizens
here should not be using their force to
replace the police that's the reality
but what's also true is that the state
is uncapable of protecting citizens and
what's also true is that in those
circumstances you cannot simply expect
people to just stay in their beds
looking how their city is destroyed the
consequences of last year protests are
still visible in this part of the city
that has since been renamed puerto rico
port of resistance this for example is a
memorial for some of the victims of the
confrontations with the police a potent
symbol of the deep divisions that exist
in this city and this country that will
face off in sunday's elections
polls show that alternative candidates
could control 45 percent of congress
most voters support a leftist coalition
called the historical pact led by
presidential candidate gustavo petro who
has a 15 percent advantage over his
closest rival their victory would
represent a seismic shift
for the first time there's a real
possibility that candidacies that don't
come from traditional liberal or
political elites could win the
presidency and control congress and this
generates turbulence a latent political
crisis
beating those who believe the time for
change has come against others who fear
it would be a dangerous leap into the
dark alessandra
al jazeera kali